we're on a 2020 binge
and we [__] watched this thing Paolo
oh [__] what let me look it up
because I can't remember his last name
it was like Mancini or some [__] Paulo
maclarini this dude we watched this 2020
on it
and 2020 kills it you know what I mean
it was a regular day in 2008 and you're
like it was wasn't it
and you're just settling in you got your
meal or your popcorn
Rebecca somebody met Paulo went in for
surgery it was a normal day blah blah
and you're like it was normal wasn't it
she was just getting surgery
but but it's not but it wasn't normal
for long and you're like you're right it
was I could tell you know I could tell
guy I could tell voice over a guy
this woman [__] met I can't believe
you should watch it I guess but you know
or I'll just tell you it
but this guy Paulo
machiarini was in uh was a guy who was a
surgeon and he was like a world-class
surgeon and he made a trachea
for people who whose trachea was [__]
up I'm very medical so that's why I'm
talking about it like this
but if you had a broken ass trachea
he made tracheas and would take your
broken ass trachea out and just slide in
a new one and then you just pop up and
be like
let's let's play baseball or some or you
know let me eat up [__] something you
know what I mean
let me breathe regular and eat full
meals so this guy
was this rock star surgeon and he would
just replace your trachea dude just like
it was nothing like it was like what
like it was literally like watching
[__] uh Dennis the Menace just that's
how he did it he was just like oh yeah
okay some people watch Dennis the Menace
and some people replace Drake yes but he
was a rock star and he looked cool they
described him on 2020 like how he was
like a little bit like George Clooney
even though he wasn't sometimes they get
a little bit confident with their [__]
he was just like George Clooney and as
you look at him and he's just like
but he was handsome and he was the [__]
he had a lot of money and um they were
doing a documentary on him
I think the lady worked for ABC or
whatever
and they were doing the the rock star
life of this Paolo
mclareni machiarini and uh
and she [__] fell in love with him
because he's such a [__] dope dude
he's like I replaced Trek it's like I
mean like for real man
if you met a guy at a party and you were
like hey what's up and he's like hey how
you doing what's up what do you do she's
like I just you know I'm
I [__] anything I bag groceries to oh
I'm a [__] News correspondent or oh
I'm I'm
I'm a doctor even if she's like I'm a
doctor
and then this guy's like that's cute
what do you do I replace tracheus
immediately it's just oh I
I had no I
okay
would you like a drink and then you buy
him the drink you understand
and so she fell in love with him and she
was doing the story on them and that's a
No-No if you don't know anything about
the journalist World which I do it's a
No-No you don't fall in love with the
subject of your [__] thing right so
but she did because the guy was so he
was just that dope wasn't he and so um
she said [__] it I quit
I want they they fell in love he asked
her to marry him and he said that there
was going to be a wedding and he's like
listen I got to tell you something I
have a really high profile
uh clientele they pay extra money and
there's like this whole it's like this
whole society and I I work on them and
these people include
Barack Obama the Pope
uh
bro he said these people include Barack
Obama the pope uh the clintons
and also Russell Crowe that's what he's
that was the fourth one which already
he's like the politicians and Russell
Crowe and I'm like hell yeah dude and
I'm thinking does Russell Crowe have one
of these tracheas in him so he said okay
I got a meeting with the Pope and she
was like Wow amazing and he comes back
after the meeting and he says I gotta
tell you something
the Pope's gonna marry us
and she goes what now here I am now I
know I'm watching the 2020 and obviously
they're showing this because this
[__] is an insane person and
either
he's lying
or at the end he kills a bunch of people
that's the only thing what happens in in
the 2020s is either he kills a bunch of
people or he up he lied the whole time
and it wasn't who he thought he was and
sometimes it's both okay so she's like
I'm sorry the pope is going to marry us
does he even do that and he's like no
but he's going to do it for us she's
like what
she tells the friends and the friends
are like what well I guess it makes
sense if he replaces trachea is and he's
a rock star they [__] and he works
with the Obamas and [__]
um
so he says yeah our wedding is in Spain
great or um
our wedding is in Spain and it's in
Whatever May
as you're getting ready everyone buys
the tickets to [__] Spain they all
spend so many 300 people by
non-refundable tickets to Spain and he
uh they buy dresses and [__] the
bride's Grooms shits and the Bridesmaids
and all this [__] and two weeks to the
wedding they're gonna do it in the
church
two weeks into the wedding two weeks to
the wedding one of the friends say to
this news reporter who fell in love with
them
hey you know how like you said the pope
is going to marry you
I mean dude this this woman had like gay
friends and he was like I can't believe
we're gonna get to go to the wedding and
the pope is going to give us communion
he said that hey the guy said hey you're
gonna give all your gay friends
communion back then the pope you know
Catholicism didn't want anything to do
with gays so
their gay guys were like crying they're
like I can't believe it you know
two weeks before the wedding the friend
calls the [__] news reporter lady and
he's like hey did you say they were
gonna get married the Public's gonna
marry you said yeah the pope is
scheduled to be in South America in two
weeks
and I'm like yeah okay because he's
lying you know and she's like what so
she calls him he says no they they
[__] it up somebody's trying to go
higher than the pope and uh and and and
and and they're using the strong I'm
like who the [__] is higher than the
pope who is it God is Jesus just like
hey you got to be sorry I know you got
to marry these [__] this tricky
replacement guy but we gotta [__]
move you down to South America we've got
to be in South America for some [__]
function so you she's like she's like
well that's weird I'm gonna call the
hotel just like it cause a hotel no
record of the hotel of the marriage of
the [__] wedding parties close the
restaurant for the rehearsal dinner and
they say no record no record of anything
so she's like what the [__] so she
decides [__] it I'm a reporter I'm gonna
play cool I'm gonna be with the dude I'm
not gonna show my cards but I'm gonna
find out as much as I can hey what the
[__] is going on just run dude he's a
liar just run and it turned out that
this guy was falsifying credentials he
somehow weasels his way in through
school made trick is the trick is turned
out to be just [__] for real water
bottles that he would [__] thin down
and put into your throat and your skin
would grow over it so 15 people [__]
died because this guy said he could
replace or trick yeah and it didn't work
dude so she showed up to his [__]
house with the non-refundable ticket at
the end of the [__] uh instead of
going to the wedding
she showed up to his house and he had
another [__] family of course because
that's how this ends but my question and
my main question is hey guy don't you
care
don't you have stress about all of this
cheating was hard enough
cheating is so stressful but you're
pretending that you're saving people's
lives replacing their tracheas and have
not one but two families already
the Barcelona [__] house he had a
family and that wasn't his may even his
main family dude
hey guy what were you going to do when
everyone showed up for the wedding
if nobody found out the pope is going to
be in South America what the [__] was
your plan
this is the most amazing thing ever and
this is true dude this isn't a movie
that stars Chris Evans probably you know
what I mean that that's the thing he
would take after he [__] shot Captain
America he's like you know what I'm
tired of these [__] crazy rolls let
me play Paula macharini the trachea
replacement guy
still with his [__] no matter what
role Chris Evans ever does I still want
him to have his Captain America [__]
shield on his back that would be
[__] hilarious dude
but dude that's the kind of [__]
sociopath if you're going to be a
sociopath that's the kind you have to be
all out dude
oh oh I don't
oh I replace tracheus you do yeah you
know the science oh yeah I know it all
and you don't and the people are gonna
die
no they're not
15 die uh it had to do with something
else honestly
they didn't keep up with their medical
plan afterwards really wait you have one
extra family no I have two I have two
great my dogs are barking so much it's
unbelievable hopefully we can't hear a
minute but if you can that's just the
way it goes man
I [__] cannot believe this guy Paolo
machiarini